[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys as you can see
uh dirt is not here today Dar has things
he had to take care of and bullet Cloud
shows up right when I go live
and it's new video
I don't know what that's about but gotta
fix that real quick guys
well technically he ain't late because
I'm I'm going a little early
and technically I I'm doing this off the
clock so uh
it is what it is a bit on time
foreign
all right can you hear us Bitcoin loud
and clear hear me yes sir I can hear you
guys man everything going good with you
guys no no
it's been like the week from hell and I
keep getting weeks from hell like every
other week
it's freaking nuts yeah I I just got
through reviewing uh Valkyrie uh Elysium
I think it was called Valkyrie
did you uh it was that game on your
platform any uh big cloud valkyrialism
uh I've been wanting to get to it I've
been on this uh it's not a crazy
Platinum uh streak so no that [ __ ] you
like the like the Platinum company
no I was on a platinum streak yeah you
know how many games I Platinum this
month
I used to be that kind of person when it
come to
to that I'm not really like that anymore
to be honest with you yeah I'm gonna
guess five
five more than five
more than 30. this month what the hell
are you playing
been playing a lot of Indie stuff oh
okay all right oh he's playing the kids
smoothly he's been playing a lot of
Triple A's deaf stranding stuff like
that uh literally went crazy and just
platted like 40 games this month
he's playing the kids smooth stuff
I know what he do I know what he doing
that's what we used to do when we was
trying to compete for um game of school
it's worse now they kids moves literally
has a publisher that he he knows the
Publisher's name and he'll search it
like every other week and they release
it when they get weekly that it takes
you five minutes to get all thousand
Gamers score that's ridiculous there's a
lot there's a lot of stuff like that too
and um nah I just been uh really
cleansing you know I've been getting off
of social media that's been keeping
distance having fun I respect the
cleansing thing King
yeah what's going on with you what you
playing man what is going on with king
um
playing anything uh I've been trying to
get to a whole bunch of stuff like right
now right after this right I had no
plans on doing the show today but me and
Eric was talking in the background and
boom here I am
um I gotta wash my dog I gotta go mow
the lawn I gotta put together some stuff
so I got a whole bunch of stuff to do
today that has nothing to do with video
games but I bet you I can get into three
games of fortnite
too late I need to play a little bit
more fortnite I haven't really played it
at all played more Fall Guys than
anything uh this season but the fortnite
for the the season just started so you
know and I'm watching and or that's on
the Disney plus Channel you know huge
Star Wars nuts so that I am and this is
probably one of the
best produced shows
any
any thoughts on it so far
got this one fly that won't leave me
alone well better than a mosquito that
sucked the side of my head post
um
disrespectful I got The Last Samurai
mosquito in my house um you don't want
to die
um it's my thoughts on it is
it's one one of the best produced uh
shows as far as you see huge production
value right and
everybody always says well Disney
doesn't put a lot of production value I
beg to differ I think that Star Wars
stuff gets a bulk load of their money I
felt like Obi-Wan was very highly Prof
like highly production wise like if when
you see this
you're gonna say oh my God they take it
up another notch and we already know
that they're acting is Top Notch so
um it's a really good it's slow build
the first three episodes they dropped on
day one to let you binge those and then
they're releasing one episode per week
so I got to I watched the fourth episode
today
and the fourth episode really kicks off
the mains character's journey to where
we got to see him in Rogue one so if
anybody watched Rogue one is the story
about that character it's his backstory
that we're doing now and it's hey boy
it's something to watch right now I
respect that uh pretty much what I I've
been like I said Valkyrie Elysium I'll
probably drop the review after this
podcast
um what's funny is I
I hope I don't break in D.A I hope to
God but there's a couple people I've
talked to the game's already out because
of the pre the the uh if you bought the
deluxe edition you got Early Access I
talked to another couple reviewers
apparently you can post stuff I see
people posting on Twitter so I'ma just
do it unless the gate comes out in the
morning I'm assuming you know if if not
I'll just private or unlist it for a
couple hours but yeah I will be
releasing that I know a lot of people
was looking forward to that game uh it
is a Square Enix game so I don't play
State it's not on Xbox go figure but
we're going to get into to the show man
you know first thing I want I want to
talk a little bit light a little bit
light plus we got King here so I felt
like I had to talk about this apparently
someone over there EA
is making an Iron Man game King I want
what I want from you is your
expectations on how you feel like an
Iron Man these days should be made
well I saw the the Michael mock-up or
demo of it and Unreal Engine uh five
um
it looks like the VR game just an Unreal
Engine five
I don't know what expectations I can
have for the game to be honest with you
uh I think they're gonna follow the
Disney template in the Disney template
of Iron Man isn't Iron Man to be per se
it was like Iron Man light for uh the
masses that can consume it in a manner
that works well for them Iron Man is a
real
hardcore character
um in in the Marvel Universe right so
for them to portray Iron Man actually in
the comic books they will have to go
into a whole bunch of his dark past you
know his his drinking his his war on the
war that he actually started that you
know his father was a war Monger his
company was a war Monger uh so they were
selling arms and stuff across the world
I know they did a little bit of that but
they tried to clean his hands very early
on and that that's not how the books
were you know he was still a war Monger
for a very long period of time
yeah and in the movies they kind of
portrayed at the moment he found out his
dad did it yeah then he just stopped it
but it seems like in the comics and
stuff he kept doing it yeah and probably
something happened that opened his eyes
afterwards the iron um the iron Wars
they're gonna deal into that in in
Disney plus uh but they're gonna deal
with that with Roadie his Tech gets out
and once he sees his Tech starting to
kill people and do things that forces
him on a different Journey that's like
when he goes into demon in a bottle that
that whole uh storyline of him being a
real drunker they touched on it and Iron
Man 3 and you know and they made it all
Whimsical but I understand movies got to
be very short for that the game I think
is going to be light-hearted I think
it's going to have some undertones of
him uh taking on some bad guys across
the world but I say this to say
in the books right now the Iron Man
armor is so Advanced so he has it as and
they have it in the in the movies they
showed the nanites and it comes out of
his body and stuff like that
Iron Man is just an AI at this point
himself Tony Stark himself because Tony
Stark is actually dead in the books but
he can't die because his AI lives on so
just like how
um
you understand like the AI that he had
in his helmet that was talking to him
that it seemed like it was alive well he
is a sentient AI so it's really
different oh I didn't know that so at
the end of like Tony's thing he made
himself into AI
is inevitable um
like he did for his uh Butler yeah his
dad his bad his dad's Butler is uh
Jarvis yeah
well I mean Jarvis in the books isn't
that but Jarvis in the movie is that
yeah Jarvis in the books was the real
Butler of the Avengers so you know they
they weaved stuff and they made stuff
work yeah explain a lot of people don't
catch on that the guy in the car next to
his dad is Jarvis sitting because he
says let's go Jarvis
quick question you know first off let's
get what's your expectations with this
big cloud when it comes to this Iron Man
I know a lot of I've seen the chat
people don't
people don't what's what I'm looking for
they don't
have faith in EA to make a superhero
game so what's your opinion big cloud
I mean I'm give it a chance see what's
up specially since we got the Star Wars
Jedi Survivor coming out and they were
they did good with Fallen um Fallen
order but as far as Iron Man is
concerned think about Iron Man uh
I always envisioned this character under
another you know I mean publisher in
general because I figured they would
tell more of the storytelling aspect of
like King was alluding to earlier like
there's a lot more depth to Iron Man
especially towards villains that you
might see in movies that was rushed like
the whole Iron Monger thing for example
a lot of people don't know how deep it
is with the iron monger and why he
really just want them dead like a lot of
people know so I don't expect EA to go
that crazy what I expect is probably
International threats uh for Iron Man
he's probably just going to be like
sinner you know kind of like was Iron
Man 2 with uh Whiplash not like his Tech
this random guy had an arc reactor and
all of a sudden you know pandemonium
starts the White House told me hey I
think he's selling under the table we
need to we need to go and take his stack
so maybe that's going to be the the
story or the basis of what they're going
to do there but I'm not expecting no
crazy like jaw-dropping like cinematic
experience like we got with Spider-Man
20. there's a reason why I hold
Spider-Man 2018 so high is because it
literally gave you everything that you
would want in the movies right in game
form like when you played that game you
weren't expecting to be fighting spoiler
alert and Dr Rock on doc doc on the side
of the building you know you wasn't
expecting I wasn't a long a lot of time
to you know that's like equivalent to be
like spoiler alert I'm gonna ruin the
last episode that happened I mean the
game
I feel like you get like you get a year
before I start spoiling stuff if you
ain't played something in a year you
weren't playing it that's right I think
bit is on to
the whole plot line of Spider-Man being
in a mature plot line yeah I didn't
think that I was going to get in the
dlc's Spider-Man is a deadbeat dad type
of thing yep and that thing and the fact
that uh you know he was going back and
forth with Mary Jane they had to explain
to Mary Jane that he had you know went
with his ex while Ed was on a break
um those mature type of conversations
that were being had and how they were
dealing with certain aspects that's why
I hold 2018 in such regard like and
develop respect for it yeah and and the
fact that they got the essence of the
character down pack you know um so do I
expect EA to uh pay attention to all the
nuances of spider of um Iron Man I don't
believe so and yeah because we don't
have faith in them to deliver in that
manner and that's a problem when you see
an IP go to a company and you just shake
your head and roll your eyes and hope
for the best yeah like I remember I'm
surprised Microsoft didn't just get this
particular character it worked with it
because this would have made sense for
Microsoft different you know custom
consoles or whatever but they they
didn't do this hell even spawn and
whatnot but again away from that
um but no like you're you're absolutely
right on that it's like Iron Man is
one of those characters that can
definitely make your console Stand Out
absolutely if you do it right with the
right story you got the right villains
you got the right gameplay from what I
saw in the demo it does look cool like a
lot of the new stuff
um but again you know
I don't know maybe this will get people
talking about Superman down the road who
knows if they if it does well am I
expecting Jedi Fallen order type of
levels of quality here
we'll see apparently it's being made by
the people who made uh Star Wars Rogue
Squadron and it's being amazed and it's
being made by the people are doing the
Dead Space remake remake I think I don't
know I think
so if it is that company here's the
thing I have a little bit more faith if
they reach out to BioWare they'd be like
yo how did you do those flying mechanics
yeah because I feel like when you play
with some of those uh some of those
machines on Anthem that is Iron Man
that's how he flies
yeah so it's just like I feel like if
they talk to them like yo can you can
you help us with the this this I mean I
don't even care let bio words just do
the flying mechanic part of it like
because it's just like you know and
especially if they don't have to worry
because I think that's a huge thing to
have to try to invent a way to do that
you know what I'm saying like to be able
to fly I think that's a big thing and
and I think the biggest thing it is is
like you know if they can get that taken
care of quick they can focus on the
stuff that matters because flying
matters it's a very important thing to
Iron Man but it's something that we
expect I think the biggest thing is can
they hit the story can they hit the game
play with the story can they hit all of
those in a tri factor and I think if
they can get that flying out quick out
the door where they they understand it
they know exactly how they want to use
use it then they can focus on other
stuff that matters such as story yeah
the government Anthem man when you uh go
to the little Hub and you jump into your
suit like you see it kind of like docked
on this on the machine it would be cool
again like you can go to like his uh
Mansion number right you go it's like
his little headquarters you can take the
shoot off and explore like the you know
I mean like his house and then you can
do this stuff seamlessly put the suits
on and try them out but I don't expect
that type of level of
you know immersion from EA as a lady I'm
not expecting it
if if they try to monetize it in the
sense that
um you have to have all these different
suits I I see the aspect of EA looking
at it and Tony has probably at least uh
well A Hundred Islands like 100 for each
situation so and you know I think they
can work in that aspect with it and
attic is right in the respect that you
know Anthem uh flight mechanics was uh
really done well and what I want
is enemy choices right the reason why
Spider-Man works so well because you had
low medium and and tough super events
right uh for Spider-Man to fight
you can have that same aspect with Iron
Man but really in the books Iron Man
isn't a street level character stopping
street level crime exactly right so
either you had corporate Espionage it's
not even like a vigilante like no he
isn't he's more of an icon he goes like
where it matters for the most part like
in the movie I saw him like go over to
like I uh to Iraq to just make a
statement that wasn't in the books
see his biggest thing like I said was
corporate Espionage and and he's really
the the most selfish hero period to be
honest with you because it's where his
self-interest lies so if it
self-interest lies in this thing
he got a Renaissance from the movies in
the books that was Reinventing Iron Man
into what he was supposed to be right so
I respect it just out of curiosity
um you know coming from a person that
enjoys the comic books like you do do
you prefer the Iron Man to stay intact
on how the the comic books portrayed him
or do you prefer uh the movie scenario
where they kind of you know altered his
his character a little or do you prefer
like a mixture maybe come to the light
side sooner like how would you want Iron
Man to be portrayed in this game
I would
I
it's hard because a selfish kid inside
of me wants my Iron Man right that the
one that I have over here if I can get
my camera to see him you can see him
right there yeah uh you want that you
want that comment Iron Man yeah that's
that's uh my master line Iron Man from
um XM Studios and the reason why I got
that
um is because of the the comic book
accurate armor
um that Tony Stark
had limitations and it was built around
the suit so he he just had just enough
power to do just enough of whatever it
is that he had to do and he had to
calculate how he was going to attack a
situation based on what his armor was
allowing him to do so in the books now
uh or the movies his armor seems
unlimited to some extent right the power
keeps adding out to it right uh
um
so
I do want it fan friendly I do like that
aspect that includes everyone into the
whole conversation opposed to just
limiting it to a section of comic book
readers that can only identify with
certain things so I do want them to
broaden it uh but I do want them to stay
true to the character so I do want him
to be as selfish narcissist individual
who goes after self-interest and the
preservation of his name and the
glorification of himself right and he
becomes uh the leader of the Avengers
only at the opposition of the true
leader which is Captain America because
he sides with the government right
that's when you get the whole Secret
Wars and all that stuff you know the
Civil War stuff I want that Iron Man I
want the Iron man that feels that he's
always right and he knows what's best
for the world to the detriment of what
your choices are so if they can attack
the character from that psychological
aspect and actually Implement that
inside the game where you know that he's
a narcissist and he's always going to
make sure that he is the smartest person
in the room that's the Iron Man I want
yeah so you have a good point uh there
too because
um
that's why I'm I'm even more worried
about it too because Civil War no
because Civil War had a good premise
yeah we didn't get a whole lot more of
that premise that tension build up
between the characters before you know I
mean cap one Rogue did a state to get
Buck you know I mean it would have been
cool to have that in game form where you
actually play as Tony and you get more
of the story you know I'm saying you go
through this you see the different
levels you see the different threats
you're building up towards in the sense
of not following I guess the corporate
rule you know I mean and see that side
then you see okay you know what hmm do I
want to be this type of hero or do I
want to do that so
uh
in a weird way yeah I kind of do want it
to have similarities to the MCU like for
example there's a lot of cool suits in
the MCU that are you know flight suits
the the God man the
Jesus Christ the war machine obviously
can be added to this in a sequel what
they ever at this effort does takes off
but
hmm
it depends really it depends on the
situation at this point and how they do
it I'm not even sure did they even give
us like a synapse of how they're going
to tell this at all no so so we just
know this project so we just know it's
project Iron Man you saw you saw the
demo of it right yeah so I thought I saw
the uh Unreal Engine uh thing where
you're flying around that looks good
like oh that looks good looks good to
what you see in the movie you know minus
the flares
that looks good but
I don't know man I feel like
I there are definitely gonna there's a
lot of questions I'll just say that a
lot of questions did you play The Iron
Man VR game no I didn't I don't I didn't
have uh pictures
I didn't I didn't have psvr I I thought
it was pretty decent did you yeah I
thought it was pretty decent VR aspect I
think
my perspective is you see Iron Man doing
uh making iron my game
let's say the Iron Man actually does
good it's a good game uh you know they
they let Vince influence a lot of EA and
EA's letting people actually take
creative freedom they're not pushing any
kind of their own agendas like
microtransactions and stuff and let's
say Iron Man does good because of these
changes
I think that puts more pressure on
Microsoft to have their own because it's
just like look like sure you get some
you get the Iron Man uh you get the
Gotham Knight stuff you get
um isn't there another game I'm thinking
of the the one uh with uh with Captain
America and Black Panther you get that
one but it's just like
as long as they get uh my Sony's about
to get Wolverine they're about to get uh
they already have something uh
supposedly there's rumored that they
have another one that they ain't
announced yet so yeah it's just like to
me if Iron Man is good even if it isn't
good I think just the existence of Iron
Man says look
these characters are available you need
to pursue one what do you think
um oh you know I'm never on board for
that right because that puts the
publisher and the developer behind the
eight ball from the start right uh
everybody's clambering and I hear it and
I hate it oh they need to punish her The
Punisher works so well with Microsoft
The Punisher works so we never knew
Spider-Man worked so well with Sony
until it was actually done right and
um Insomniac had did uh what was that
game that they did with uh Microsoft
first
um
uh Sunset Overdrive yeah Sunset
Overdrive right and you saw the
traversal mechanic that was started in
that aspect all the other Spider-Man
games that were released that was um
from a claim from Activision all those
Spider-Man games in some form or another
sucked in some way except for probably
Maximum Carnage and the one that was on
the Genesis
um Ultimate Spider-Man Ultimate piano
yeah there you go yeah that one that was
good but they were all a progression to
what we ultimately got and I believe
that was a lock behind the tech in the
right developer I think those things are
organic and they come together at some
points as an apex in in the gaming space
we don't get a superhero game like in
the sense of Superman because again that
small medium tear and large tier
characters that he has to fight
Spider-Man Superman has no pair to be
honest with you as far as stream Speed
and Agility and stuff like that so you
have to form something to to hurt him
that's why Superman games don't reach
that Apex yet I don't think the tech
that we have yet is able to attack a
Superman game in that form a whole game
suffers the same thing
do you think do you think that
where Iron Man and Superman both need a
lot of the game being revolved around
flight you think that might be an issue
too to like yes make a game play that
revolves around flying because I don't
I don't think people realize
and Sonic was able to do Spider-Man
because there's a lot realistically
that dude can only do so much you know
what I'm saying he could swing around
Towers like but when you add flight to a
game like full straight blown flight
it's different and I don't I don't think
people realize like the amount of work
it probably goes into I'll probably
reach out to someone get them on here
and see how hard it is to bring flight
to a game on like that but it's just
Superman
I've always felt like one of the biggest
ways that you can give him give him a
solid game is like when he when he's
younger and he's learning how to use his
powers and he can't full-blown flight
you know what I'm saying like he he can
progress at the end maybe or something
yeah because I've seen I've seen enough
on Superman to know that he he would
jump first before he could fly yeah yeah
and like maybe something like that an
Iron Man you know there's a lot of
things they can do I think they can make
an Iron Man game before Superman game
because I think Superman
who's he gonna fight straight criminals
one person and they're gonna throw
against the wall
comes down to the um to the to the
writing really I mean you could you
could basically write it to him like
remember like what was it uh Superman
Returns man he came back after years of
being away why not have him come back in
the world be kind of into chaos similar
to that dream sequence in Batman v
Superman and have it be Bizarro
it would be nice to have insomnia
Mandingo Mandingo he knows I'll be
butchering these names okay uh it would
be nice to have insomnia level story for
Iron Man the only thing EA nailed are
flight uh mechanics from Anthem keeping
my uh
thumbs up or hopes up I I agree with you
I I do think that
they can make one especially they've
shown that we can do the fly thing
especially the robots of flight thing it
just
it depends on how much influence is
gonna that EA themself is going to put
on this the the studio
I feel like
where you know at that that point where
Capcom everyone just assumed they were
going to go under
and it's just yeah
everyone just assumed it was just a
matter of time
and it was there it's like lightning in
a bottle they hit Monster Hunter and
that put their company back on track
yeah I think we're about to see the
early stages of EA getting back on track
and I think I think Jedi Fallen order
might have been that Catalyst that shows
EA look we could still do the stuff to
make us money
but we got to be a little bit more fluid
to get people
here we got to be a little more fluid
and more open to different ideals so
other people will try out our games and
not just have Madden 23 Madden 24 but
and I feel like they see that Madden
name might not last forever because they
just had to give up the FIFA name so I
let's be real if EA lost to sports do
you think they would stay around long
like the whole program is built around
the sports aspect
um it's very hard to Pivot and to turn
into some listen uh uh third person
story driven games are a Dying Breed
right so you have to turn it into
something that is able to produce cash
EA very early on got on the sports scene
and realized that the reoccurring of
revenue from these sports games allows
them to generate cash at astronomical uh
rates while exploring different ideas in
these games
um if they lost that aspect their
company DNA is built in sports EA Sports
is in the game and everything else is a
derivative of that if they lost that I I
probably would cry that day because I
know that that developer is putting a
perilous uh downward spiral and for them
to catch lightning in a bottle to do a
fortnight type of game because it will
have to be a games of service and would
not be a third person story driven game
that would save them
that would be hard that would be the the
scary part for that and I think that's
my biggest thing of Iron Man you know
if they let the developers develop
instead of trying to reach the hand in
the cookie jar and take out cookies
before they come before they're made
then I could see the game doing well
because I can see a lot of creative
because
I bet you if you went back and I don't
know how you guys feel about it if you
went back you took 100 of the scale of
games that flopped
it did really bad over hyped games and
you went back and you dissected that
game development you would see somewhere
in that line the publisher put their
hands in the cookie jar first oh you
know we like this microtransaction you
know what can we put that in there
because I know they did it with Dead
Space Three that's the other fear for EA
too
um who's to say you probably gonna be
paying for a lot of these suits they're
from the MCU or they'll have some system
in play like that I guess to me as long
as the gameplay mechanics the gameplay
the story everything's fine
so I'm not like you guys I don't care
about the suits I'm gonna be real with
you I don't as long as the story's good
and the in the base suit is fine you
know what I'm saying like I don't I
don't like like Spider-Man you didn't
really see
the suit interact too much during the
story you know what I'm saying like I
don't see races
no you to my damage like like I'm
talking about like Batman level where
like the like by the end of that game
but he looked completely different than
the beginning of that game uh he his
suit was damaged the advanced suit was
damaged and ripped up and stuff like
that yeah it changes too yeah he had to
get the what was called the biosuit yeah
right yeah crazy as hell like the whole
biggest aspect of the Spider-Man 2018
was the suits like I would I would
literally do something over just because
I got the suits when I got the Clone
suit out of that I guess maybe
see I didn't change the shoes or
anything like that so I guess that's oh
no
oh my God
[Applause]
hold up hold up oh one second king you
already know what happened when you get
the bio [ __ ] you started immediately all
over and playing Edge or in the Bible so
I'm skipping about it I will switch when
I got a new suit I would switch to it
look at it for a second and switch back
like I did like that stuff doesn't mean
anything to me like I'm not Elijah bring
it up then it gotta be a cultural thing
it gotta be a cultural thing because you
brought it up you were talking about the
suits not me you said EA was going to
charge separately for them
no because no I was saying as long as
that is done where the suit's damaged
and and you could see that he's been
through some stuff then I don't care if
you can't buy another one like my thing
is like I I want to see that Evolution
like I saw in Batman where you know you
throughout the game but maybe it's
because Batman in most of those games
Spider-Man's done throughout a couple
days and like Batman is pretty much done
like one night in in city and then the
original Batman was done in one scenario
so I can understand Spider-Man would
have the opportunity to go switch suits
you know what I'm saying like Batman
didn't really have that opportunity and
so it's the rich history of the costumes
that play a large part but see okay it's
it's individuals
attic and I can give you an Insight
attic really doesn't care what we wear
when we go to these shows he doesn't we
that's up to me right so it's up to me
to literally how it goes I wake up in
the morning when I put in the group chat
what color are we wearing today
he doesn't care so and I can I
understand it so when he says it it
really it's really not
um far-fetched for it to happen for for
me to be a disbelief with it I believe
it it was just like really in that game
and that game was really around uh
unlocking each suit and what you had to
do to get to said suits and Miles
Morales was the same way you know what I
didn't change his suit one time
[Applause]
he eventually gets a new suit in the
game itself like the black one like the
remade one like that's I played that
from the the start to the end like
Spider-Man 2 what we saw in the trailer
they all have the base suit that you've
seen on the cover of each game though
they those are the version two their
versions of those suits yeah refined
versions so doc OCT makes the advanced
suit okay right which is like it looks
orange it looks kind of like it's like
orange tint to it that's the Prototype
Advanced suit Peter's version goes bad
traditional colors when it has more
similarities to what Peter would put on
a suit and part two and what's funny is
I actually I'm a huge fan of Miles
Morales I thought that was a fantastic
game I actually said that was better
than the 2018 one but uh yes I did use
gadgets okay just now let's see this is
what I'm like just because I said I
didn't switch to thought people were
like did you get that yeah it was funny
I didn't use a lot of gadgets but I did
you guys didn't use the web bomb it's
because like like the melee system and
The Swinging system was so op you didn't
have to use half that stuff half the
time so uh it was just certain certain
uh
certain ads and certain enemies you had
too but besides that I didn't really
have to mess with too much stuff we got
a two combo in the game web bomb and
concussion yeah I used one I use that
you got two dollar super trap from Donna
Taco we need a Superman Warrior game I
don't I know what he's talking about
all right so that that's uh and if give
me let me know if I'm right or wrong Don
um that's when uh he was depowered by uh
War manga and
um
he was on that planet where he didn't
have his powers and he uh he had to uh
fight uh to to get off of that planet he
was it was they tried to take the
concept of uh Gladiator Hulk where uh
Hulk had that stun disc that was on his
chest that made him weaker and he wasn't
able to turn to World breaker Hawk and
he was able to be in Gladiator
tournaments where his life was on the
line he was strong but he wasn't as
strong as Hulk strong so maybe uh they
can do a game where Superman is on a
planet where uh he is de-powered because
of the sun the sun is let's say is
instead of the yellow sun is a red Sun
and he doesn't have the ability to
absorb the powers from the Sun and he
has to he's at a limited form and he can
go about it that way that concept itself
where it strips some of his flight it
forces him to actually be competitive
and as you you learn different things
you can progress and get stronger and
stronger so you can get off of that
planet I think that is a great concept
for a game let me know if I'm right
about that though that'd be cool but
King here's another one though um
obviously this game is already a game
for it you know Injustice I know you've
read the comic Injustice boy why not
have that single player formed and you
play a Superman and you actually see him
go against the lantern corpse and stuff
like that
that'll be good that would have been my
my take I would have taken it to that
type of level so then you're talking
about an Intergalactic uh Superman
whereas this is how you nullify the
thoughts of the flight itself that he's
able to fly from planet to planet so you
encumbass that into it and uh when he is
on set planets he's able to go from
point A to point B but you can also have
him fight uh the indigenous population
that is probably overpowered that equals
the thought process of does his power
equate to uh fighting uh low-level
characters I mean that works not just
that though think about the set piece
they can do with this like you know you
start off you just see his descent going
into the madness of him becoming a
tyrant that's what they never did yeah
remember he went into he went into the
ocean
he pulled Atlantis out from the ocean
and put it in the desert
disrespectfulness
[Music]
so we got a two dollar Super Chat from
uh he said okay let me read the Super
Chat first he said say it with me added
Mandingo mcfickens uh so uh you know I
appreciate the pronunciation class I
appreciate it uh but I'm probably still
gonna butcher your name I'm gonna forget
that in 10 minutes but Mandingo
mcfickens you have your name pronounced
correctly for a whole five minutes so
congratulate yourself on that I think
that's the first person that has super
chatted me the correct pronunciation for
their name you know what my hat is off
to you I have a beanie on I ain't taking
it off because you should zoom in on the
little fly that is driving attic nuts
yo I just saw him and I thought it was
on my screen I was like no that's at
attic's house
it's just it's just one just keeps
flying around me like it is what it is
I'm not I'm not trying to focus on it
because then it's just gonna annoy me
and we got two dollar scripture from
Donald talking no I mean like Dynasty
Warriors or Superman oh yeah you're
ridiculous when I'm this giant like
mythology thing what you think he is
what's funny is they've done so much
with Superman they had a scenario that
made sense to you on that Super Chat and
it wasn't even nothing related to that
because it's an actual book with what I
said so I thought he was talking about
that
all right so you know what we're going
to do is uh we're actually going to go
ahead move on to this next topic I'm
actually really interested about this
let me let me do the the time stamp
thing because of the the time stamp
please we're going to do 52 minutes for
the time stamp police it's only the one
guy that bothers you a region no there's
a couple people they usually say it in
chat like he's the only person that's
real aggressive with it but there's a
lot of people that enjoy it but I called
the uh the time step Mafia that's what I
call them like if I don't if I don't do
the time stamps they're gonna come over
here and put me two feet under well six
feet no they're doing two feet because
they yeah hey cam Moses I would agree
with you if we didn't get the Batman
oh my God no no now people are super
chatting the pronunciations of their
names
I would have definitely agree with you
but yeah a lot of their shows and
everything have not been uh handled
properly at all on the DC got a two
dollar super trap from Robo not rubber
knob uh that's Steve the fly addict uh
well Steve Needs to Go Away
Steve to fly we got a five dollar Super
Chat from let's read the Super Chat
bless uh bless up guys addict yeah baby
Farva your baby
your baby's father okay I get you man
but like I said man see I'm gonna have
to like eventually get like a like a
text document and just have all these
pronunciations on it and when you guys
do purchase
when you got super chat I just control F
on the dogs
you can have her reading it she sound
like Siri
from your baby father
actually I might look into that I know
that's possible you can't do that I know
that's possible but the problem is is I
don't know if there's a way to do it
when I tell it to do it because I know
you can do it when they Super Chat in
general but I don't know if there's a
way to do it when I'm like yo read these
names you know what I'm saying because I
don't want them to I don't want it to
read during us talking because that's
going to be weird all right so we're
going to be talking about Ezra yeah
certain Affinity they are apparently uh
I think this is Jeff Grubb because I saw
it said uh feature beat might not be
Jeff Grove I don't know if Jeff grubb's
still with them or not no it's published
by Andy Robertson
so apparently
we've already known this but I think
it's more in the in the news now certain
Affinity is working on a huge project
for Halo uh and it's and he says the
biggest thing we're doing that public
right now for more than two years now
which I think we kind of knew it was
being worked on for a while and he says
uh we're doing something unannounced
that we're doing League development on
in an unannounced Day from a concept
designed it's something big and new for
the franchise but I can't say any more
about it at this moment the that's our
single largest project of our of our
three projects currently we have to
close a hundred developers working on
that so there's a hundred developers
working on this game
and I'm pretty sure it's the BR mode uh
you know it I hope it's the BR mode
because at this point I feel like they
can do a really good job at captivating
it's just first off what I want to ask
you guys is do you think it's the BR
mode and second off I want to ask you is
it you know considering all of us I know
King you know being King play a decent
amount of battle royales I want to ask
you especially King you can uh time it
on a little bit uh bit cloud is how
would you want them to do a battle
royale and how do you want certain
Affinity to do it we'll start with uh
King let me get these super chats real
quick uh two dollar Supernatural from DS
uh d t h t h x one one three eight I
think that's Wolverine I don't know
we're not we're not talking about that
uh Deadpool times The Wolverine MCU
phase six 2024. okay King you got three
minutes
[Music]
yeah I hate the Hugh Jackman I wish you
would have stayed dead but they they
gave a scenario where the movie uh Logan
was made in 2029 and this movie takes
place way before he even gets to the
that advanced stage and that advanced
stuff and that's a whole different
timeline
um I wish they don't bring them back I I
wish they had news Wolverine
yeah but I believe
um the actor that uh plays Ryan Reynolds
who who plays Deadpool I think he has a
lot of pull yep uh when it came to that
and I think he told them and this is the
reason why Deadpool's taking so long
I'm not gonna do Deadpool with a
different Wolverine unless it's you
because I'm not gonna all sacrifice my
movie to live or die on if they even
like he's got a point he does what do
you think why do you think his movies
rated R but blade King is PG-13
well the cursing it's it's more of the
cursing I think Ryan Reynolds is my
probably one of the like one of the
actors in the industry right now well
like not gaming but you know the movie
yeah they got the most clout at
everybody this man just walk up it like
and you know what's funny is in terms of
gaming I respect that man when he did
that movie uh about the uh he's he's at
NPC in the uh oh in the video game
free guy that was that was amazing I
love them especially at the end where he
starts turning like he starts because uh
because for those who don't know he he's
an NPC he learns that he he's in a video
game and then he starts playing like a
player like we would become sentient
yeah and then he gets all these items
from doing this and then the game's
starting to get deleted and he's
starting to use items from games like in
his fight he used cavities Captain
America shield he used the portal gun
hey did you see he ended up using the
the fort night uh yeah My Little Pony it
acts like it's hilarious and I honestly
feel like only Ryan Reynolds could have
did that movie I don't know why but
that's like a certain humor that only he
can do
yeah he he is very soulfulware and he
understands breaking the fourth wall and
engaging the audience is what made
Deadpool popular it's what's making
She-Hulk popular for some people not
others uh misogynistic pigs
um and
oh God you're gonna come after me with
that
um
I don't care
um and and I know he made free guy
because free guy actually broke the
fourth wall a lot as well so all right
so you know ah Cobra Kai King I hope you
saw season let me go ahead uh five
dollar super trap from rubber knob do I
really need to explain how my name is
announced I think I wrote I think I have
is it not rubber knob no it's the Rubber
knob
I'm just going off of what uh uh
sovereign
yeah I'm just what I'm gonna do is from
every time that uh solve reads a super
chat now I'm just a favorite voice and
I'm gonna just push a button on my steam
deck and it's just gonna play it and I'm
not you know what it just might work
all right then we got two dollar super
trap from flame that says this gives me
hope Halo has a Dev team again yay uh
all right let's get into it so King how
do you feel about certain Affinity do
you think it's a battle royale which I
think we all agree on that and if it is
a battle royale how would you develop
how would you want one developed
okay
um me personally if I'm making a game
I'm gonna make it like uh ODST
all right and I'm not going to be
worrying about Spartans I'm going to be
worrying about ODST Marines and they
come down in their little drop pods as
you know you're landing on the field and
it plays in the same manner of Pub G
um with uh the fortnite mixture of as
far as the Aesthetics uh you have a
season pass you have tons of content
that is the biggest problem with with a
lot of battle royales if you don't have
the content to reoccurrent content to
have people play uh then the game is
going to fall flat you gotta balance the
mechanics of the guns and the Looting
aspect and the shrinking of the map it's
out there for you um you can just follow
the blueprint uh I honestly would say go
to a slower
um Battle Royale as like fortnite but if
you're going to a faster Battle Royale
which is more Twitchy like Call of Duty
type of fortnite type of Battle Royale
like war zone and that stuff then then
then then really hit that war zone
aspect but I think the more realism
towards it for me it's better but I
think Halo is going to fall in between
is going to probably uh go a pack go
towards the um instead of the hero with
Apex is going to go towards the Call of
Duty type of feel of it and I think
they're going to lean into that aspect
but I really want it to be like ODST
Marines a little bit above regular
Marines and a little bit below Spartans
what do you think big cloud I'm curious
what's your opinion on this I don't
think I've ever talked to you about this
uh do you think it is made it is going
to be a battle royale mode and how would
you want it developed I mean I'm not
expecting him to break the fourth wall
like uh like fortnite while the crazy
stuff I ain't expecting that but how I
would do it I mean knocking Bob a good
point I would have it just be more so of
a hybrid of war zone and fortnite
elements of both and just uh probably
put it in that
um oh yes uh style as well with the
Marines I probably would do the same you
know what I think would be cool I don't
know how you guys will feel about this
you drop and I don't know if it would be
fair
but you can drop in as an elite or human
[Laughter]
and you have faster speed when you're an
elite yeah I I think that like what
about see here's the thing okay
let's say Okay clearly I'm hijacking the
conversation hey guys uh so I think they
should do both and now hear me out hear
me out all right this is going to sound
crazy and I know it's probably not gonna
work but this is this is my world so
I'ma say it the way I want it all right
so you could choose between a Spartan
odsd or an elite or even if they don't
do uh Spartan to make it more fair do a
brute brute Elite or here or an odsd
they all have different unique things
that make them unique and that make them
different aspects in the battlefield so
if you're fighting a brute he might have
a little bit more Health than a human if
you're fighting Elite he might have less
Health but he's faster for fighting an
odsd maybe he's just an overall better
like he's just average like he's got
he's got more Health uh than uh than an
elite and he's got he's got more speed
than a brute so I think that would be
cool and it's like and to make it a
little bit fair for the odsd because I
think it'll be fair regardless
um but make it to where there's stations
on the map to where an odsd can turn
into a Spartan and like it's like kind
of like one of those things where it
drops but don't make the Spartan like
like broken or anything like that you
know what I'm saying like it's just like
imagine where it's like instead of the
uh of them dropping a a a a Dragon Ball
Z capsule uh King they say on the map uh
they're they're a factory is opened or
something and then you're fighting to
get in the factory and then it'd be like
one of those things to where it's it's
four like four squads only one person
could turn into a Spartan so the other
three have to protect the one person why
he's being augmented on
so I feel like that would be that that
would be a lot of different aspects now
clearly say basically in all aspects no
balancing look I'm not saying it's going
to be easy to balance but I'm saying in
order to get in the BR right now you
have to do stuff unique stuff no
WingHouse is doing you had Apex that
made it a Hero Battle Royale no one was
doing that that's the reason they
succeeded you had war zone that already
took the did my live go off
will they now people were saying live I
don't know okay maybe okay oh yo live
okay talking to the chat am I dumb okay
so
all right so and then you have you had
Wars on Zone that took the pre-existing
fan base they had to jump start a battle
royale then you have fortnite doing
fortnite I don't even have enough
they're the first one so I guess you can
actually give them that leeway
in order to survive these days you got
to do something different
um I I guess I just feel like putting
variables in the map now it's like I
said don't make this Spartan broken but
he's gonna have to be a little bit
like a little bit of a beast because if
you let three people and I'm not saying
it's not one of those things King where
no one knows like I want if someone is
getting augmented I want every
percentage being shown imagine you
finding your way up because you know
someone's about to be turned into a
smart in there and you're hearing on the
intercom uh process is done in 30
seconds and you're like oh my God I
gotta get up there like right now like
like I just think that would be imagine
the crazy maps that you could have you
can make a reach map you can make you
can make a uh us
um what's that uh High charity map
there's so much things you can do and
it's just like
I know that that sounds crazy that this
doesn't make sense look I I get that I'm
telling you uh what's fun speculation
said you could do stuff with dark time
dark Maps where the their nighttime and
stuff all I'm saying is when you go into
something like this you got to be unique
I would rather them
make Hail Marys yeah when you die you
become a flood stuff like that like
there's a lot of different options that
you can do
like and imagine like certain of the
maps like instead oh one's instead of a
circle with a flood is infecting
like if you come out like it you're
starting to get attacked by somebody
getting attacked by the flood I mean
that's cool I I think you guys are
overthinking it
I am I am I am
I I want them to kneel the essence of
Halo right as we play the the battle
arena
um we realize that they got that essence
of Halo down pack really well all right
um
the season thing has something different
I want them to nail the essence of Halo
the same way Warzone nailed the essence
of Call of Duty
right I want them to stay true to their
identity there
don't don't try to be Fortnight and put
kamehamez I'm saying yeah you know right
now you know um
excuse me
build to these places but but put your
feet down stamp your feet in the ground
if if it's go if you're going to have
brutes if you're going to go through
three different fractions then Ensemble
do
um the the Halo Wars right
and I thought they crafted that Identity
or stayed true to Halo and that's what
made it really really good the story
talked about it was it was fantastic the
storylines was great and they and it
worked
I want them
to focus on what some of us feel I I
always thought ODST was probably one of
the best Halo games because it puts you
in a different position
of a character that wasn't op he wasn't
a Spartan but he had to still battle and
he still had to make it through uh this
war so if we can eventually worry about
odsd or more op the the they're they're
not OP but like they're more badass than
a Spartan because yeah they go into
these no they don't have a ton of armor
protecting them and that an energy sword
will kill them
so why don't we worry about the grunts
of each fraction right so we can have a
uh with the elites we can have their
lower levels instead of the actual ones
with the armor and it's super egetic and
stuff like that and and with the brutes
uh and like you said they have different
types maybe you have a little bit more
armor if you're brute but you're a
little bit slower but you can still
forage and and get weapons and the map
does shrink maybe the flood is something
good maybe it's a beam from Katana
that's actually shrinking the map
whatever it is they can work that into
the storyline of it but I want it to
feel like you know like Halo but I
wanted to feel War light so it has to
deal with the grunts you know Spartans
and these Elites they are small aspects
of a larger battle that's going on and
they tip the scales of the battle while
it's happening but to to be all honest
with you master chief goes and liberates
a bunch of captured Marines when he's
playing Halo infinite and those Marines
actually turn the tide because he can't
be at on the map at the same time all
over the place so so that's that's what
I'm looking for so you think they should
make like an evolved War uh Wars uh War
Zone from Halo 5. I think that I can't
remember what it's called chat correct
me I don't think it's called Warzone
it's called something else I can't
remember what it's called that big
battle thing that we was doing before
yeah like a more arranged version of
that once it's instead of doing a battle
royale they made it like a 50 on 50
thing yeah
well because I feel like the only way to
make a Halo version that makes sense on
Battle Royale doesn't make sense in the
long scheme of things because odhd
wouldn't be fighting each other you know
you know what I'm saying so like if they
that's why I feel like
doing it that way would you would strip
more battles yeah large-scale battles
would work out well uh but you know if
they want to do the Battle Royale that's
why I said like you have to do something
unique and you have to have it's more
about setting up scenarios that your
competition cannot set up
yeah and if you just put a thing where
guns are loaded on a map and you're
loaded on a map for instance they do a
battle royale they can they don't need
to come down on like a like a um
like a uh like a plane or the battle bus
all it is is it shows you the map at the
beginning
yeah it's called Warzone I guess it
shows you the map at the beginning on
Battle Royal for Halo and it's just like
a little Crosshair that you go down up
left right with you find out where you
want to drop you press a and it shoots
an odsc drop pad right there yeah like
there's no like parachuting like
obviously because I feel like in order
for this to work like first off if
you're a smart and you don't need a
parachute you can literally jump it uh
second off I feel like it would be very
beneficial to have fast gameplay like
that because if you think about it
imagine if you're just sitting there
and you're you're walking up and someone
respawns like obviously they have a
respawn system and you just see an ODS
theme pod fall right in front of you
like you know what's up you know what's
about that
and then that's why I say like I'm big
on if you're gonna make something you
got to do what you need you got to make
it to where memories happen on your game
that cannot be duplicated in other
competition because I think people get
this they get this weird concept that if
they make a product that's on par or
fortnite they can beat fortnite no no
fortnite is the way fortnite is for
multiple stings and it has nothing to do
with the the combat uh sure it's fun to
shoot it's got shooting good shooting
mechanics but what makes fortnite is how
mainstream it's become where you can go
in there it's just about anyone you can
think of in this whole world anything in
in multi-string I mean obviously
wouldn't work if the combat wasn't there
it does have good combat and they're
good at
what's what I'm looking for it they will
change it at it at a hair if they need
something changed that could change it
almost instantly obviously it takes a
couple weeks but a lot of these other
people it seems like it takes them a lot
longer but you know I think that's the
biggest thing King it's just like I
don't want certain Affinity to spend all
this money
waste all these resources and they
didn't think more out the box and they
just try to make a a Clone War uh war
zone you know what I'm saying like yeah
it's like it's got to be unique and it's
got to work because I don't think Halo
infinite can handle much more stuff
popping off so my person ain't there so
whatever happens happens so certain
Infinity do what you can man but do it
right that's all I ask that's all I have
all right let's go to the main event man
let's go to the main event let me let me
let me handle the time stamp uh Mafia
real quick we had an hour
and I'm going to say I'm gonna say 14
minutes because I'm gonna I'm gonna give
you guys a little bit of a of a thing
all right actually you know what I'm not
saying I'm gonna say 13.50 there you go
45. give you a little bit more man 45
minutes all right
so the the I always butcher his name
what's the CEO of Microsoft right now
probably yeah right there young Odin has
come outside and he's been very open
with supporting the Xbox brand to the
point where he is low-key calling out
PlayStation if you want to compete with
us let us compete and stop crying on
Twitter that's literally for those of
you who don't think that that's exactly
where that was going for he sure he
might have been talking to a news outlet
but he was really talking to Jim Ryan he
was talking to the camera the message
was was clear yeah so so big cloud
well how what's your thought on this
what what do you think is going to be
the result in this do you think it's
gonna breathe fire fire the PlayStation
without stops they should do the point
things can't do the boys
stop snitching and you know maybe that
those say okay this is just what
Microsoft's able to do or do you think
they might double down and snitch some
more I mean well first of all the whole
thing is just dumb and it's the fact
that it's still that's gotten to this
point is even more funny to me
personally because I thought it would be
done
in record time I guess you can say it
but no it continued to happen now I get
it I get where Jim's coming from yeah uh
Call of Duty accounts for a big no like
it comes from a big portion of Sony's
engagement numbers when it comes to
multiplayer sure but you have 10 games
as a service in production right now you
have already you already got the word
that you're going to continue to get the
games what in the next three years or
three years after the deal is done and
those you have contractually you know
with them so you're gonna get those but
the fact that he's talking about it like
yo uh it's it's so viable to us all this
stuff he's making all this late
at this point in time especially after I
don't know if y'all played model for two
Japanese the beta
no I I don't I don't know
okay you didn't if I played Modern
Warfare two I I don't know okay I feel
like I'm getting sick like I need to
stop yeah I don't feel like I'm getting
mad I played Modern Warfare 2 on PC and
Playstation I could say it right now
um and a lot of people are divided
especially after the way that game is
not only performing but just the like
how they went about that game for the
multiplayer most of the stuff that
people complained about throughout the
Decades of this game being out here on
the market they have brought back and
have either doubled down or simply
didn't listen to years of feedback that
people have given towards this franchise
so what I'm saying is
um at this point in time I don't think
Sony really needs to be worried about
Call of Duty at this point now unless
what I hope happens happens right I
talked to King about this where we
talked about uh unionization getting rid
of everything that is wrong you know I
mean people in charge getting new
leadership changing perspective you know
I mean different ideas around unless
that stuff happens with this franchise
and with this uh
you know this publisher as a whole one
this deal is done
I don't know what to really say you know
I mean Call of Duty is it is what is for
me but I I don't see the the fuss
anymore but just because I see it
doesn't mean that there are people who
are gonna play this game
and Sony at this point in time I just
feel like yo listen it's not
it ain't that deep you got God award
that's about to drop in November you got
Spider-Man 2 for next year you got
Wolverine coming out you got other games
to look out for uh you have pretty much
your
um
God your deal not even your deal I was
supposed to deal with fortnite but they
got their thing going on with Epic
and you have
all this other stuff so I mean it's dumb
to me personally I don't believe I don't
care as much about it as far as what
Satya Nadella said for years I've asked
for Microsoft to compete so the fact
that they are competing now and putting
pressure on Sony what what it really
tells me is that Sony doesn't want to go
through what we they've been through
with the PS3 gen again where they had to
legit fight to finale for everything
when it came to Microsoft
and
I get it but you're in a you're in the
best shape you've been in a long time
you don't have a system that's all you
know overpriced significantly overpriced
and you know hard to develop for no you
have everything working in your favor
you have a loyal fan base that's willing
to pay 70 for games you have a royal
family has won the pay and eat the price
hike you know I mean and buy these
consoles so it's not like you or any
particular situation where you're
falling back the problem is you don't
want to really compete for the for the
past couple years Sony's been in cruise
control
since the PS4 gen
that's how it's been they've been in
cruise control think about it as what
what threat have they actually had to
worry about since the ps4j
not really much of anything none they've
been in cruise control just sit back to
collect their reward pretty much exactly
so that's how it's been they don't want
that type of flow that steady flow
happened and um
you know that styled us
how do you feel King you know I know we
went over this little bit on uh on IOP
uh I I'm curious let's change this up
just a little bit do you think that what
what uh Jim Ryan has been saying on not
Twitter but you know media outlets and
stuff do you think that that has sparked
even more of a fire behind Microsoft and
Phil Spencer and stuff like what are you
what's your thoughts
well
Phil is always going to take the
politically correct
thought when it comes to stuff and he's
always cognizant of the fact that like
he said he's he he's all about inclusion
right
and I think he's been uh benevolent
across the boards with as far as sharing
and stuff
um
Satya is probably
tired
of the backbiting the bickering the
public displays of outcry uh from the
the people that's in the number one
position supposedly if you have all
these things going for you if you have
everything supposedly right you have a
fan base that's delusional enough to
fall for 70 dollar games one and done
games if you have a fan base that's
delusional to fall for uh 18 service
that is really eight dollars I broke it
down to people
um if you have a fan base that is uh
willing to pay the price hike in a
console that's already existing on the
market there was one price yesterday
that's a new price today if you have
done all this customer abuse and these
people are still standing by you and
they're still with you why are you
worrying about somebody it's fourth and
fifth the reasons is because you can see
the writing on the wall you know um
this this generation didn't start off
how they wanted it to start off to be
honest with you uh I don't believe that
Microsoft started off this generation
exactly how they wanted to but I believe
that they're in a better position as far
as planning goes to where they're going
to reach their final form a lot sooner
than what the PlayStation would and now
removing stuff off the boards removing
Revenue off the boards actually hits uh
Sony in the pocket Jim understands that
part
Jim is a money guy once the market
starts to hit and hurt Sony's Pockets
they're going to look over at Jim
I think it was a statistic out there
that Sony is uh like what 50 percent
down in Revenue sharing this year uh as
far as a company as a whole goes not
just saying that you know it's a
PlayStation but that plays a large key
into some of the stuff that is limiting
them from expanding in certain spaces
it'd be a chip set speed uh the console
distribution it's a lot of things but
Satya saying that he wants competition
let us have competition
um if if it's solely about this aspect
then let's keep it about this aspect and
top stop goal post moving that's what
he's trying to say stop trying to use
your uh your tactics your business
tactics in one area to try to influence
another area if it's about competition
then we know what we need to do to
compete with you on the levels that you
think that we can't compete is going to
be a point in time where after that
Activision uh you know blizzard and King
deal goes through
and Microsoft starts attacking the
portable Market
and then the blizzard games start coming
in not worrying about the Call of Duty
games those games start to roll in and
start to come in
Satya young Odin is going to compete in
the way that he knows how
he's going to open that checkbook
and he's going to start looking at
companies
that fit the Microsoft portfolio
he's going to start looking at companies
that can actually put out quality games
in the Microsoft Game Pass ecosystem
and those games are going to be the
future of how the gaming landscape is
going to be divided
Sony realizes they don't have the Bucks
to compete in that aspect so they have
to cry out and have to you know show
different things it is nice
Satya has a plan I believe Microsoft as
a whole has a plan
and Game Pass was the vehicle to get
that stuff into your house once it's on
every television once it's in every
mobile device that's the whole takeover
aspect of it so you just want to have
your games in this service revolving as
much as possible with as many developers
that they can actually house so if if
it's about competition
and you all wanted competition all I've
ever heard from Sony dudes for forever
is well Microsoft needs to compete in
this space well now they're competing in
this space stop crying and snitching
stop pointing fingers stop yelling oh no
you know we need no what what kills me
about that they're saying like Okay so I
get like okay so they're like yo
Microsoft's taking games from this side
and not letting on this side but it's
like
we're ignored we're ignoring Final
Fantasy yeah I'm saying like it's it's
it's
more than Final Fantasy we're ignoring
all the business tactics that they've
been doing for years Final Fantasy is
just the highlight of a small aspect of
the tactics that they've been writing
into contracts and stuff like that so
well definitely just dropped on Xbox
yeah yeah like how why did it drop
immediately because well it couldn't
drop immediately
yeah right it was that clause in the
contract right yeah
they pay for exclusivity this is what
they do so when you own these companies
they can't go in there and pay for
exclusivity they have to eat that that
bag they have to find out other ways to
compete and does Sony have all that
money to be making one and done games no
this is the reason why uh Jim is
pivoting to games as a service this is
the reason why that aspect is going to
change in the PlayStation Nation they're
going to be games of a service they're
going to have these revolving games
that's going to be there with season
passes and stuff like that and it's
going to look like a multiplayer Haven
when Microsoft built the whole company
on right so as as far as Xbox goes
that's going to happen they were on the
right track
Sony was good for last generation
high-speed internet digital transfers
digital purchasing digital aspect the
way we live and the The Limited
attention span of the gamers that we
have at the moment
geared towards these battle royale's
these games as a service these quick
twitch games that actually keeps
generating levels of money
these those
uh nuances before that was Niche is now
Mainstay these are the big bucks
carriers these are the big games so I
think you're going to see larger aspects
of that transpiring and they're going to
compete in those Arenas I just feel that
Microsoft has the war chest that allows
them to participate in this in a
different manner than Sony and Sony
realizes that so
if it's about competition well you got
it now bro
and they're in trouble after this deal
yeah I think Sega is next how would I be
surprised yeah that was my choice
because most of the stuff they blocking
is to fix a problem you know I mean it's
the main problem
so they bought the they bought Bethesda
we said they needed more IPS more stuff
to go for they got that what's the other
thing that people been asking for for
Xbox
jrpgs yep
so makes sense there you buy Call of
Duty now this is where I get because
everybody else saw my halo earlier how
do you feel because I never got your
take on it but how did you feel about
Kayla taking a back uh basically a back
seat if once uh Call of Duty gets thrown
into game pass because I think that's
going to be the way it's going to be you
know I mean like cod's gonna be the
poster boy of the console going forward
and Halo will be more of a second player
on the side you know what I mean because
I don't think Halo is going to get that
obviously I don't think we're ever going
to see a a game that's going to be like
multi like heavily like a service from
Halo ever again so they're gonna have to
go back to the traditional formula you
know I mean but I don't think so you
don't think so I think they have enough
Studios to actually rotate and and
regurgitate different type of stuff
um I think Halo will always be the
staple of the box
and infinite the way that they're
structuring 343 and uh building that
stable I I
um
I believe once they get the Cadence down
once they get all the stuff that they
have to put out like forged uh the co-op
all that other stuff that is slated to
come out once that stuff does come out
and it can focus their attention on Halo
infinite the game itself I believe that
that game itself will be exactly what
it's supposed to be I think they're
going to scale back uh Call of Duty
that's not going to be a every year uh
release I think it's going to be every
two year release type of game I'll give
it some time to cook a little bit and I
believe Warzone will be that constant
for them that can continue to generate
Revenue the biggest thing is not really
Activision's Call of Duty the biggest
thing is really King King is really the
whole vehicle that Microsoft is going
after they're going after that aspect
and blizzard
well blizzard of course for the RPGs
because I think Microsoft wants to stamp
their self as the RPG King and it would
lead sense for people for um
for Microsoft to purchase Square
to to Shore that up but I will honestly
I believe Atlas with Sega
is a bigger catch see well let me
interrupt you real quick
I want them
to buy Sega I want them because it's I
think that's a more logical move yeah it
would give them a lot in the jail but
let me get these two super chats real
quick before I forget them I appreciate
the one uh the dollarship shot from Mr
orange I like that name Mr orange and
then we got a uh a two dollar secret
from T Forest I definitely should have
said something for us but I appreciate
the uh support
there you go so thanks Mr here here's
what I think not like
the the the the relaxed person in me
he's like I want them to buy Sega you
know the the industry the person that
you see on IOP or sometimes because
sometimes we're messy on there for the
most part sometimes I want them to buy
sexual you know because I think that
makes the most sense they have Studios I
like I feel like they would get a good
uh grabbing when it comes to Japanese
jrpg but the messy addict to me wants
them to buy score in it because I want I
just want to see Twitter for one day one
day like can I just see what would I I
can't even I can't sometimes you know
how people say I can't fathom I can't
imagine what would happen if a certain
scenario happens I literally could not
imagine what would happen if they bought
Square Enix
I do yeah you know what would happen you
know what happened complete meltdowns
this is the typical I'm done with gaming
I'm going to PC
s
you can go to PC and play with Xbox
controller another thing I want them to
do is I want them to to migrate game
pass into bottleneck like I wanted to
migrate that whole time because I feel
like that makes the most sense PC wise
yeah I just I think that
look we have waited a while and I think
it's fair for people I never jump on
people who say they're done waiting I
get annoyed when I know people are
capping and they've never waited because
they've never cared about the brand from
the start they only say stuff because
they want to suit they want the illusion
they care about where the brand goes but
they don't really care where the brain
goes if anything it benefits them more
for the brand to stay where it's at
because they can still generate more
income off clowning them on YouTube
Twitter that's where my issue is it's
like look if you are generally an Xbox
user and you've been waiting for a
certain game for years and you're
frustrated you have every right to be
but I do feel like there's going to be
a great time where we're still got a
little bit longer to go I do think that
some of these games like outer worlds
too they're coming sooner than you think
yeah uh but I do think that you know you
probably got another six months to a
year before you start seeing these
titles gameplay gameplay because there's
going to get to a point and you can mark
this it's it's 9 28 2022 there's gonna
be a point
where you going to tell them to start
announcing new IPS because they show you
too much gameplay it's gonna be a point
where every event they have is going to
be Gameplay trailer after Gameplay
trailer after Gameplay trailer because
that as at that point they have the
content to show you I think they're not
done buying I think the only reason I
think PlayStation has secretly been
sitting behind the computer like oh God
this deal is about to end that big Pape
that big bank account's about to open it
up again oh God oh God because if if
anything you know I think a lot of
people were relieved when Microsoft
uh uh there that they did the opening
stuff to buy Activision because I
honestly feel like if they didn't buy
Activision they would have probably
bought WB at that point when they
started selling individual Studios
there's a chance they would have bought
score enix's Western Studios yeah all
across the Dynamics and stuff yeah did
they it's just Microsoft's been fighting
with one hand behind their back and and
keep in mind
even if they got good stuff to show it
doesn't strategically make sense for
them to show it right now because right
now
you're trying to appeal to people that
are going to cost you billions if you
mess up
if you come out there and you announce
all this new stuff all this new gameplay
it's going to be hard to sit there
because Microsoft is really in a better
position trying to act in a weaker
position yo lean number four thing
number one why are they coming at us if
you start going up showing all this
stuff it's going to look like you're in
a stronger position than you actually
are do they sit there and see Microsoft
as this week week uh this week company
in the corner no but Microsoft wants to
show like look we're in this industry
and we're doing what we can
but you got to let us buy this company
because it's one of the key factors we
need to compete and that's why you're
seeing that they're not really making
moves on a lot of third-party stuff
because
they don't want to give anyone any more
ammunition to attack them when it comes
to this deal yep
so you know uh you know we'll go ahead
and talk about it real quick because
people will talk about the chat and you
know uh I have to actually let me put
this in the uh in the thing because uh I
didn't where we are right now for your
time step Mafia we're one hour uh we'll
say we'll say 36 minutes 36 minutes
let's talk about grounded for a couple
minutes
uh the game officially released and
I want to hear you guys opinion on how
well received this game is getting right
now it's it's kind of insane like you
know the Honey I Shrunk the Kids again
yeah Honey I Shrunk the Kids game and
it's getting a lot of good praise like a
lot of good praise
uh so you know to make a quick thoughts
because you know obviously we want to
get us up it's not one hour and 26
minutes I got the official time stamps
on my end damn okay the official time
stamps uh so I just want you guys
opinion real quick you know what you
guys opinion when you saw how well
ground is being received
we'll start with uh Keen well initially
uh from the beta and stuff like that or
other open preview or whatever
it it played well
um they fixed all the stuff that they
were doing while I was playing it uh
from one passion project to an ultimate
uh double A Plus title uh to actually uh
get fruition to actually ship and to
actually get praise after said shipping
um that means that that what they should
have did with um sea of Thieves
uh they they didn't do they released sea
of Thieves and it was in a broken State
and it built to the state that it is now
they did correctly with this game were
grounded and that that teaches you that
Microsoft learns right so we can do this
in beta 5 how long it takes to cook and
get the game done and we can tinker and
do everything that we supposed to do and
when we're completely satisfied with
this game then we can release it and it
releases to a round of applause I think
that was a great strategy but I think
that sea of thieves was the sacrificial
lamb to learn the process and this game
actually uh got the fruits of that labor
so
um it's great to see
um maybe one day we can play this game
in a community stream you know against
people it's a very streamable your mic
is muted yeah type of game yeah so yeah
um nothing but praise to the team at a
civil obsidian and um
to actually get this game out to
actually stick with it and to actually
show how fun it can be then a review
stick to it that's great what about you
uh bit Cloud you know
um I give my own opinion but I'm carries
for your opinion man what's your thought
process on Grounded uh you know I
wouldn't even say this game has never
been successful I think it's been
successful the entire time it's been out
but after they release the actual last
patch that you know I think put a lot of
the campaign functions in it a lot of
people are really loving it I mean it
was never on my radar I never really
um looked at it's like in the direction
of it but the fact that they're doing so
well I mean hey good for the team good
for the game
um glad everybody should join it that's
the best I can say about it I mean I got
nothing really crazy to say towards the
team
yeah so you know I think when it comes
to me is
I just like the success rates man if
there's anything I like more than
anything in this industry it's when
something does well because I feel like
a lot of games deserve good
good and good Happy Endings I felt like
if anything that shows that shows up
City don't miss
they and you got the outer worlds hit
out of the park you got just about
everything hit out of the park
it's just crazy anything don't miss but
you know let's go ahead and do these
these outros man king where can the
people find you at where can they find
you can find me at IOP Sundays at uh 1
p.m this weekend uh I believe that we
have the the Jake Paul versus
um oh what's this guy named Silva yeah
Anderson Silva I thought that was next
month is it next month I thought it was
oh no that's October 29th okay good oh
thank God thank God because I thought I
thought I had a fight this weekend he
knocked out Ortiz you seen that right
recently uh Silva you know yeah yeah
boxing
all this stuff is exhibition stuff it's
it's his entertainment this is fun stuff
but uh you know Saturdays at 10 p.m if
it's a major fight on us if it's in the
Zeitgeist that you know a king the
professional fan will be on combat talk
talking about it um attic and I is uh
we're putting the finishing touches on a
show
that him and I is going to do
um
we have to wait a little bit first and
foremost everybody that's in Florida or
everybody that's in that region of the
world but that's going to go through
this hurricane my heart goes out to you
us guys it's crazy really don't deal
with that so
um just be safe you know
um do everything that you got to do
follow all the guidelines make sure that
you have enough food and water to you
know sustain yourself if if you do lose
power uh we know a lot of guys out there
like you know my boy Mojo my boy's sick
uh we have graphic God we have a lot of
people out there uh uh DJs
um just uh my my guy Ty just please be
safe uh please follow all the rules and
don't go out there trying to film The
Hurricane don't go for cloud man your
life is not worth Cloud it's definitely
not worth it just just try to be as safe
as possible let's all get past this
stuff uh because it affects everyone but
especially those people there please so
please you know be safe yeah it's it's
like King said you know
be careful out there man don't do
anything to put your life in jeopardy
you know I saw a lot of videos that I'm
just like why like look like there's a
good chance that nothing's gonna happen
to you I saw like going over
um going over like one of the rivers
over there it's just like a dude on a
porch on a porch just watching it go buy
him and I'm like look chances are you're
not gonna get hurt because it's a good
amount of weight and it's going the
other way but why even risk it why risk
it pulling up something on the other end
of that Lake just throw right in your
face like so the go in be safe don't do
dumb stuff for clout cloud is not worth
it man cloud is not worth your life big
cloud where can people find you at man
YouTube twitch Twitter big cloud that
she could find me big cloud gaming big
cloud appreciate me yeah you you you
guys to find me uh most iron Lords um
well there's a game.net Ireland oh yeah
that's right what what shows you have
these days going on you still do the uh
thing
yeah um that's gonna be
uh for the time being that's gonna be
Saturdays at around I think you said
Saturdays at nine I guess we're doing
that an rgt podcast obviously Friday at
5 p.m probably six uh for that as well
that's what's up you know and obviously
uh myself catch selling the iron Lords
podcast every Sunday at 1pm uh like us
we do this every Wednesday at 5 p.m most
of the time dirt's here but Dirt has
some family stuff to go through I'm
gonna try to get a hustle on here again
eventually to guess because I know he's
been busy with a new job and everything
you know appreciate for coming hey we
had like 350 people at one time
definitely hit that like button let's
get that above 100 and uh we'll say 70
70 man 170 likes I would appreciate you
get those likes up hey you guys show up
every week man every week show up to IOP
show up to the attic show that's why
we're gonna do more stuff I'm gonna talk
to the boy I'm gonna try to get us a
grounded string going on in the next
couple weeks I don't know when we'll try
to do it maybe not all of us gonna be
involved but I'm gonna try to do it uh
I'm going to be
invade I have a premier stream going on
here in a couple minutes well actually
here in about 30 seconds I'm gonna send
you guys over there man listen to you
guys over there uh it will be my uh my
review on Valkyrie Elysium or I don't
know what that thing's called it has
like a weird name I can't pronounce
American names half the time much less
Elysium no someone in the chat you know
you know Elysium well at least he might
be Elysium
I gotta see your um your thing yeah
someone in the chat man you know what to
do and uh you know I appreciate everyone
for coming through we'll be here like uh
Sunday uh 1 p.m I don't I don't even I
don't think we have a guest I don't know
why I have to look even if we can just
have fun even if we had to guess I'm not
a lot so Elysium there we go Elysium but
like I said I appreciate everything you
guys do and we'll be back next week and
I'm gonna send you guys over to my
review now look
whatever that happens with this review
it happens whatever stays on the
internet whatever happens the internet
stays on the internet so this is Lord
addict King David and big cloud and
we're out laughs
[Music]